tornadoes and hailstorms are some of the
most damaging natural disasters in the
world
thanks to tools like modern weather
radar and a new lightning mapper weather
forecasters can give advance notice for
people to take cover
but what if there was a way to give even
more warning
help may come from satellites
in 2018 researchers published a paper
showing a connection between severe
storms and cloud plumes that flow like
smoke out of them they compared hundreds
of plume storms with radar lightning
data and severe weather warnings
storms that were strong enough to make
these features called above anvil cirrus
plumes or aacps were also more likely to
have severe tornadoes large hail and
high winds
they often appeared 10 to 30 minutes
before severe conditions on the ground
spotting an aacp could save lives by
giving people more time to duck and
cover it could especially help in places
without radar
until now researchers haven't fully
understood how the plumes form
but a new study provides some insight
into that question
scientists simulated an aacp using a
numerical model and environmental
conditions known to produce severe
storms
typically storms stay in the troposphere
the lowest part of the atmosphere where
we live when these storm clouds rise and
reach the stratosphere they often
flatten out creating an anvil-shaped
cloud
in stronger storms the air rises much
faster and higher
the clouds punch their way into the
stratosphere and create features called
overshooting tops
aacps are the wispy cirrus clouds that
form near the overshooting tops
in the new study researchers examined
how these plumes formed when fast
stratospheric winds collided with an
overshooting top
the winds flowed up over the top and
then plunged downwind so fast they
caused something called a hydraulic jump
hydraulic jumps are easy to see and
features such as dams or rivers
when water flows too quickly the flow
will abruptly change
the hydraulic jump is where smooth flow
becomes turbulent
they're also common on the backsides of
mountains fast winds flowing down
mountainsides often leap upwards when
they hit a barrier to their flow
that's why a plane landing near a
mountain might take you on a bumpy ride
curiously the new model showed the
storms acting like a solid mountain or
river rock even though they're made of
fluid
the stratospheric winds had to move
around the storm
in the future the scientists plan to
study the role aacps play in climate
change
according to the model plumes can shoot
more than 7 metric tons of water per
second into the stratosphere
since water vapor acts as a powerful
greenhouse gas in this layer
the plumes could warm the lower
atmosphere even more
creating a cycle of rising temperatures
if the researchers can use tools such as
radar and lidar to confirm their model
our understanding of severe weather and
its climate impacts could take a big
leap forward
[Music]